OK.
I have a gas slight alert for you today.
Gaslighting is when you manipulate someone
into questioning their own ability to understand
the world.
And the new gaslight phrase of the week from
the Trump administration is we are now testing
more than South Korea per capita.
And this is this is going to be a painful
one because it is such a weaponized this information.
But I do think it's important to do this.
This is the anatomy of disinformation for
you to understand very, very clearly.
So we have a corona virus pandemic.
The way we find cases is by doing tests for
the virus.
Right now, they they've all been RNA based
tests.
An antigen test is now in development and
may soon be available.
But so far, you find cases by doing RNA tests,
which require a number of different elements
in order to do the test.
So far, so good.
South Korea and the United States find their
first respective cases of Corona virus within
hours of each other.
We often say January 20th.
I think one was January 19.
The other was the 20th.
With the time difference, it may have been
simultanous.
Doesn't matter.
Within hours of each other, South Korea and
the United States confirmed their first case.
South Korea immediately developed a test,
ramps up testing capacity tests.
Lots of people establish his fever clinics
to isolate people who test positive contact
traces, exposed contacts of infected people,
puts them in home isolation, and they do a
fantastic job with the virus, all while not
being authoritarian.
Remember, South Korea is ranked higher than
the United States on the Demark Democracy
Index.
That was January.
Now, Trump didn't do that.
We didn't get much testing capacity until
the end of March, which is.
Essentially, two whole months during which
South Korea developed tested contact rates,
etc., we started to ramp up testing at the
end of March.
If you looked at the numbers of tests that
we were doing in the first part of March,
it was numbers like 600 tests in an entire
day.
We got up to a few thousand tests per day.
Our testing capacity was terrible at the time.
We were about 50th or 50 fifth in the world
per capita, maybe even worse.
I don't remember exactly.
Now compare our testing numbers in early March
to South Korea's positive test results by
early March.
South Korea was finding sometimes eight hundred
positive cases in a day.
And there was a period in early March where
South Korea was doing so much testing that
they were finding more cases than the total
number of tests we were doing.
Understand that comparison.
There were days in early March.
We South Korea and the U.S. had our first
confirmed case on the same day.
Days in March where we would do X number of
tests and South Korea would have that same
X number of positive tests because they were
doing so much more testing than us.
This allowed South Korea to stop the spread
very, very early.
Now, over time, during March, April into May,
our testing rate continued to really lag.
We were testing 50th in the world than forty
fifth in the world per capita than forty first.
Currently, our testing rate is about thirty
thousand people per million.
That puts us 40th worldwide in testing per
capita.
This is as of a few hours ago.
We are behind Singapore and Canada in per
capita testing, but we are ahead of the Czech
Republic as examples.
And as we were failing during March and April,
reporters kept asking Trump and other officials.
You keep saying we're doing a lot of tests,
but what about per capita?
Because per capita we're not.
It wasn't clear whether Trump understood what
per capita meant and or was pretending not
to.
We didn't know the talking point was.
We've done more tests than anyone in the aggregate,
but of course, per capita was what was relevant
at the time.
The new talking point now is, hey, everybody's
talking about South Korea.
We now have more per capita tests than South
Korea.
That is true.
And in fact, our testing per capita is now
double that of South Korea's.
But why is this gaslighting?
It's gaslighting because South Korea barely
has any cases.
There is no point now in comparing us to South
Korea because South Korea barely has an outbreak
at this point in time.
Look again at South Korea's curve.
South Korea hasn't had more than 150 cases
in a day since March 11th.
That's not a typo.
I want to say that again, South Korea has
not had more than 150 cases since March 11th
in the US.
We regularly have a thousand fifteen hundred
two thousand twenty five hundred deaths per
day.
South Korea has not had a day with more than
150 cases since March Eleven.
That's two months ago.
So the point is, of course, our per capita
testing rate is now greater than South Korea's.
They have nobody to test because almost no
one has the virus.
We have a third of all the global cases.
South Korea has 258 deaths.
Total, total.
South Korea has two hundred and fifty eight
deaths.
The Trump administration is now bragging that
our per capita testing rate is higher than
South Korea's, but it's actually an embarrassment.
It took months for us to get our testing rate
to match that of a country that essentially
eliminated the outbreak two months ago.
And we are still only 40th in testing per
capita.
There is no serious reason to even mention
South Korea anymore other than to say that's
what we should have done.
They handled it correctly and we didn't.
This is the new Trump is talking point.
Trump is using it.
Kaili McEnany used it yesterday during her
press briefing.
We need to be testing more.
South Korea doesn't even have sick people
to test anymore.
There's no reason to continue comparing ourselves
to South Korea at this point.
South Korea is an instructive example for
what we should have done on January 20.
That's almost three months ago.
Let's take a quick break.
Almost four months ago.
All right.
Let's take a quick break and we'll be back
right after this.